on february 11th 2013
pope benedict xvi in front of the
college of cardinals
and in front of the world retired as
pope
he cited his age and lack of strength of
mind and body as the reasons for his
resignation
his retirement took place on the 28th of
the same month
and he was succeeded by the current pope
pope
francis it had been almost 600 years
since the last pope had renounced
the papacy but this video is not about
this pope benedict
but a different pope benedict pope
benedict the ninth
the first pope to willfully renounce the
papacy
before we begin it is important to point
out that through the history of the
papacy
99 of popes held the title till their
death
before benedict ix there had been a
number of popes
who lost their position before dying
these men did not do so willingly
however
they were usually driven off into exile
in other words they were deposed this
is not the case with benedict the night
born theophylactus of tusculum the
future pope was of noble blood
his father was a feudal lord the count
of tusculum
this position was one of the most
powerful in medieval italy
and especially in the city of rome he
was also the nephew of two previous
popes
pope benedict the viii and john xiv
keep these two facts in mind not
much is known about his early childhood
but when he was a young man his father
bribed the officials of rome to make the
aphalactus
pope some sources say that he may have
been
as young as 11 or 12 but most historians
agree he was about 20.
you may be wondering how this happened
you can't just bribe some random public
officials to become
pope right you have to be elected by the
college of cardinals
we've all seen the cgb grave video after
all
well before 1059 there was no uniform
way to elect a pope
officially the pope was chosen by a
college of bishops in the area in
and around rome but this election was
often a rubber
stamp of sorts for the selected
candidate it was usual for instance for
popes to choose their own successor or
for important kings and emperors to put
their preferred man in place
at this time the officials and nobles of
rome held that power
and so they were bribed by the count of
tusculum to put his son
in this position making him pope
benedict the ninth
in 1032 the papacy at
this time was as much a political
position as it was a spiritual one
the pope was the monarch of the papal
states as well as the leader of
all of western christendom and this was
even before the great schism
when the eastern orthodox church broke
from the catholic church
so the pope had considerable sway in the
east as well
a family who had a pope on the throne
was a powerful family indeed
and as was previously noted benedict had
two uncles who were pope before him
and while it's not unheard of for
families to have political dynasties in
democratic systems
in this instance it was not so innocent
in catholic history this period is known
as the tusculum papacy in which
three successive popes were put on the
papal chair
because of the meddling of the family of
tusculum so
already we're off to a bad start but
let's not judge old benedict too
quickly just because his father bought
him the papacy
doesn't mean he'll be a bad pope right
wrong
benedict ix papacy was racked with
controversy
he was accused of a great number of
atrocities from
rampant corruption and bribery and even
murder and rape
theologians and historians have called
him a demon from hell
and a disgrace to the chair of saint
peter in truth
we don't know how accurate these claims
are in the 10th and 11th centuries
the church was extremely fractured and
corrupt many of these accusations
may have well been overblown by the
political rivals to benedict and his
family
still it is safe to say he was a
negligent pope at the very
least as nothing of significance is
attributed to his reign
his papacy was so controversial that in
1036 he was
run out of rome and forced into exile by
city officials
he came back quickly however with the
help of the holy roman emperor of the
time
conrad ii but only a few years later
in 1044 opposition to benedict's
lifestyle again led to his banishment
from the city
this time the church actually replaced
him electing
sylvester iii who was a member of the
crescensi family
the main rivals of the tusculums in
september of that year
but again he came back while in exile
benedict gathered up an army and marched
into rome
deposed sylvester and was back on the
papal throne
that's a lot of excitement already and
we haven't even gotten to the point of
the video
after taking back the papal seat
benedict started to become
uneasy he wasn't certain that he could
hold on to the papacy
and on top of that it seemed he was
rather over the whole thing
he expressed interest in mary and his
cousin and since
marriage was obviously not allowed for a
pope benedict ix
decided to abdicate he went to his
godfather
the priest john gracian and consulted
him on his decision
john agreed that benedict's leaving
would be in the best interest of the
church
and so benedict offered john the
position if john would reimburse
benedict for some of his expenses
essentially benedict sold the papacy
to his godfather john gracian accepted
the offer
paid the money and was elected as pope
gregory vi
contrary to what you might think pope
gregory was seen both by
his contemporaries and by historians as
a pretty good choice for pope
he was well respected and really cared
about seeding out the corruption in the
church
he was ultimately unsuccessful on that
front
but a for effort so that's the story of
the first
willful abdication wait what the story
isn't over
benedict apparently growing bored of his
new life and
new wife came to regret his decision to
abdicate and
sell the papacy so what did he do well
gather another army and storm the city
of rome of course asserting his claim to
the papacy for the
third time in his life he was successful
in taking the city
but none of the clergy nor the laity
recognized him as pope
instead sticking with gregory hearing
about aldous kerfuffle
sylvester iii remember him decided this
would be a great time to reassert
his claim to the position as well so by
the year 1046
there were three count em three
claimants
to the papacy quite the mess
over in the holy roman empire emperor
henry iii was hearing rumors of chaos
down in rome the place he was
supposedly emperor of a number of
italian bishops
and laypeople had sent messages urging
him to march down the rome
and bring order to the city and so he
did
in december of 1046 the council of
suttree was called to try and fix the
mess
and hash out who would be the next pope
it was decided that none of the three
claims to the papacy were valid
and a new pope would be chosen pope
clement ii
benedict actually didn't show up to the
council at all
and refused to accept the council's
rulings
when clement ii died he tried to take
the papacy again
but was expelled by german forces he was
excommunicated soon after
it is rumored that he later regretted
the whole affair and saw the error in
his ways
pope leo ix lifted his excommunication
and benedict died in 1056 being buried
at the abbey of gratiferata
so that's the story of pope benedict ix
the first pope to willfully step
down as pope and then reserve his claim
as pope and then refused to step down
when he was asked to
hopefully that gives you a good view
into the chaos of the early papacy
and the convoluted and corrupt politics
of the middle ages
we can take comfort in that today's
papal renunciations
are done quite a bit more peacefully
thanks for watching